welcome to this week's edition of world
stories USA Donald Trump and Florida's
Cuban exiles Germany a taste of nature
but first to northwest Pakistan and a
beautiful region close to the Afghan
border here former Taliban fighters are
being offered classes in D
radicalization
the picturesque setting of the Swat
Valley in 2007 the army led a military
operation here to clear out the Taliban
almost a decade later behind the walls
of this former hotel soldiers are trying
to deter and d radicalize would-be
terrorists the fact that such a center
is still needed shows how hard the fight
against extremism is michelle has seen
over 1,500 men come through its doors
since 2010 we were not allowed to
identify the current class they have
either been members of terrorist groups
or have helped jihadi fighters each
program lasts three months where the
students learn vocational skills and
attend basic religious classes the army
claims a success rate of ninety-nine
percent Muhammad Ali was just 19 years
old and a university student when he was
persuaded to head to Howland in
Afghanistan he was trained by the
Taliban who threatened to kill him when
he tried to leave authorities arrested
Mohammed once he came back to Pakistan
jihad ki ki KI monatiquot sister Jihad's
real meaning is a person's individual
struggle but in their language they said
it means to kill people or be killed
yourself when I heard this definition I
thought it was the truth according to
Islam and this inspired me I didn't have
enough knowledge about it at all nah
elimina ties jihad guevara minh muhammad
is due for release soon and is convinced
he will not go back to his old life the
men aged from just 18 to over 70 and the
resident psychologist says they posed
multiple challenges your social problem
what their war home cause those who have
social problems we give them counseling
we teach students with a low IQ and give
them tests and those who are religious
extremists we have scholars who tell
them the true meaning of our faith
religious scholar has Giada tarun career
/ karate here sixty percent of
Pakistan's population is 24 or younger
experts suggest the crises in education
health in the economy provide a ripe
environment for radicalization these
students at Peshawar University say they
are often frustrated we don't have a job
market here because of the law and order
situation people are not investing here
there was a lot of militancy in my area
in heber agency so we somehow managed to
come here but most of my classmates of
the metric they were radicalized and now
they have died the government says
addressing the complex issues that fuel
terrorism remain a priority but change
will not happen overnight security
officials will be closely monitoring
mohammed when he is released though it
will take years to fully assess whether
the centre's attempts to D radicalize
him have been successful
Islamic extremism isn't just a problem
of the middle east pakistan or
afghanistan in nigeria for example the
terrorist group Boko Haram has abducted
thousands of women and young girls if
you ever get the chance to escape
christina isabella is getting the
results of her health check-up they show
she's doing okay physically at least a
month ago the twenty-year-old escaped
from Boko Haram militants they'd kept
her captive for almost two years during
that time she was repeatedly raped now
pregnant she's gone to live with her
cousin dissolution jamana no kitchen no
mukashi the melon was kept telling us we
had to get married Lukaku a wooden dummy
cocoon Kiwi we resisted at first but
they became more brutal and would beat
us over and over again though her latina
Emily they ended up blindfolding and
choosing one woman who put up a vice
eventually when they threatened to kill
us well we just gave r32 who you this
was so so mu Odin dude when her relative
saw her again they were shocked by her
Haggard appearance the product of two
years of almost unimaginable horror of
course she's not the only victim she
says the kidnap chubak schoolgirls are
among around 2,000 women Boko Haram
militants are holding captive in forests
near the border with Cameroon a queenly
firm will the others were close by but
were completely isolated from the other
prisoners of the Apache once we saw them
reading some girl Ron they were all
together the coastal area earlier this
month Nigerian President Muhammadu
Buhari held a meeting with a chip off
school girl who was rescued from Boko
Haram but there are countless other
victims like Christina habla whose cases
don't receive such attention she's
receiving neither psychological nor
financial support
those who've escaped face the challenge
of reintegrating into society the coming
but may really be may pose a danger to
the society because of the reorientation
develop gotten from their captors we
have to show them love accept them open
our arms and welcome them home they
should we at least take in two different
way gravitational Center Christina
job'll and her cousin can't fathom why
the two box school girls have received
so much more attention than other
victims of Boko Haram she's not looking
for a meeting with the president but she
does want support for herself as well as
her baby
now to the US city of Miami home to over
a million Cubans many of them staunch
republicans we took to the streets of
Little Havana to ask people what they
thought of Donald Trump's campaign to
become the next president
in a district of Miami known as Little
Havana Cuban exiles enjoy a game of
dominoes the most conservative of the
city's Cuban community generally support
the Republican Party in the US but with
Donald Trump almost certain to win the
Republican nomination November's
presidential election may prove
different won't forget that a
presidential nominee doesn't talk the
way that manner talks he reminds me of
what's his name in Venezuela he talks
the same garbage gzz ya got me mother
for these Domino players say they're not
impressed with Trump's moved so far and
they're not going to join in his
political game as a president he'll have
cruel policies towards people who have
to come and live in this country those
who have to leave their home countries
because there are lots of problems in
the world with poverty and politics and
with political leaders especially Lucia
Ramon has been living in the United
States for about 20 years despite her
Latino roots she says she supports
Donald Trump a empresa que trabajan
there are thousands of Latinos working
in Donald Trump's companies and all of
them are happy with him because he's a
man who whenever he falls he picks
himself up again even if he might fall a
thousand times yes and that's what Latin
Americans are used to seeing the message
he gives to the Latino community is that
this is a country of space and
opportunities Lorenzo Palomar is a
former Miami candidate for the House of
Representatives is Trump's Latino
spokesman he says the tycoon's political
ideas have been misunderstood senior
don't know mr. Trump did not say that
anyone who crosses the border is a bad
person what he said was that anyone who
crosses the border without the right
papers is committing a crime see and
that among those people there are
thieves rapists drug traffickers and
other bad people but some of those who
come here are very good people the fact
is that crossing the border in that way
is a crime in the United States every
country has its borders and citizenship
rules and they must be respected
topoisomerase oh la frontera unis over
any a llegar a pet Ursula palomares is
convinced
mccann candidate will win November's
election with the support of Latino
voters including the cuban-american
community a grave concern for some a
grand hope for others the controversial
tycoon clearly has many in Miami's Cuban
community talking
to Germany now we're an initiative in
Berlin has begun taking people on a
culinary expedition to explore the taste
of nature in the very heart of the city
she is he customer mammals they're out
on a hunt searching for something to eat
at last they taste some success a lime
tree in a berlin park welcome to the
world of Moon River or mouth readers
it's hardened that he isn't a tender
leaves here are the best just pluck them
and try you'll be surprised at the
venison muscles Everett is a first-timer
he advises companies on sustainability
now he's discovering another aspect of
green living it's French sponge other I
think it's very interesting I found
about this on the internet I didn't know
there was so much to eat less income
when drought is an organization that
encourages people to go back to the
nature and discover it's known and
unknown treasures on today's menu is a
tree salad the moon roi ba are scouting
for all available leaves and flaws in
the neighborhood the leaves are
specially tasty between april and may i
want to show people that nature is chest
at the doorstep and wherever Nature is
there's something to eat it's now time
to relish the riches of the natural
treasure hunt a salad made of rovenia
flowers and lime tree leaves spiced up
with spruce shoots as obvious permeates
about Eileen I'm not sure if I'll eat a
lime salad every day probably not but
when i pass by these plants next time
I'll recognize them and that is a great
experience the mouth Raiders learned
that there is an alternative to pack
salad from the supermarket and that too
right in the center of the German
capital
you